Add a pop of culture to every room in your house with SiriusXM. Stream over 425 channels of ad-free music, plus exclusive talk, world-class news, live play-by-play sports, comedy, and popular podcasts with the SXM app. Subscribe to the streaming platinum plan and get your first three months for free. Visit SiriusXM.ca for details.
使用 SiriusXM，为家里的每个房间增添一抹文化气息。通过 SXM 应用程序，您可以畅听 425 个以上的无广告音乐频道，还有独家访谈、世界级新闻、现场体育赛事直播、喜剧和热门播客。订阅流媒体白金套餐，即可享受前三个月免费。访问 SiriusXM.ca 了解详情。
SiriusXM, everything you want to hear lives here. MUSIC Our episodes deal with SiriusXM and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website.
SiriusXM，您想听的一切尽在此处。 音乐 我们的剧集涉及 SiriusXM 以及往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用程序上或我们网站上的本期节目简介。
This episode involves a crime against children. It may not be suitable for all listeners. Aboriginal and Torres Strait Islander peoples should be aware that this episode contains the names of people who have passed away. Nestled in the hinterland of mid-north New South Wales is the town of Bowerville, which sits about 20 kilometres inland from the coast.
本期节目涉及针对儿童的犯罪。可能不适合所有听众。原住民和托雷斯海峡岛民应注意，本期节目包含已故人员的姓名。坐落在新南威尔士州中北部腹地的博韦尔维尔（Bowerville）镇，距离海岸约 20 公里。
The fertile lands in the surrounding area led to a booming agricultural industry over the years, with farmers raising cattle and growing produce such as bananas, macadamia nuts, and avocados. Bowerville itself was constructed around the timber industry, but the area's natural beauty is equally notable, characterised by rugged bushland. Life around Bowerville has often been described as sleepy,
多年来，周边地区的肥沃土地催生了蓬勃发展的农业，农民们饲养牲畜并种植香蕉、夏威夷果和牛油果等农产品。博韦尔维尔本身是围绕木材产业建立的，但该地区自然风光同样引人注目，其特点是崎岖的灌木林。博韦尔维尔周围的生活经常被形容为沉睡般宁静，
with locals more or less keeping to themselves, but eventually city dwellers started moving to the area in search of a tree change. It was easy to see what drew them there. Driving through Bowerville's town centre, it looks like something out of a picture book. Quaint heritage buildings lined the main street, ranging from an art deco-era movie theatre
当地人或多或少安分守己，但最终城里人开始搬到该地区寻找田园生活。不难看出是什么吸引了他们。驾车穿过博韦尔维尔的镇中心，它看起来就像一本图画书里的景象。古朴的遗产建筑排列在主街两旁，从装饰艺术风格的电影院
to Victorian-era pubs. In 1990, the town's population numbered around 1,500, but there were really two Bowervilles. The town was home to about 150 indigenous residents, who all too often experienced racism. Most of them lived around an area known as The Mish. Sprawling along a street then called Cemetery Road, now renamed Gumbagya Road,
到维多利亚风格的酒吧。1990年，该镇人口约为1500人，但实际上有两个博韦尔维尔。该镇大约有 150 名原住民居民，他们常常遭受种族歧视。他们大多住在被称为“The Mish”的地区附近。沿着当时名为墓地路（Cemetery Road）、现更名为甘巴贾路（Gumbagya Road）的一条街道延伸，
The Mish was a row of houses on the outskirts of town, away from the gentile-looking buildings that were so attractive to tourists. Its name came from the unofficial Aboriginal mission that had been there between the 1880s and the 1950s. During Australia's civil rights movement in the 1960s, activist Charles Perkins led a freedom bus ride through Bowerville to protest discrimination against Australia's First Nations peoples.
The Mish 是镇郊的一排房屋，远离那些对游客极具吸引力的绅士风格建筑。它的名字来源于1880年代至1950年代期间存在于那里的非官方原住民教会。在20世纪60年代澳大利亚民权运动期间，活动家查尔斯·帕金斯（Charles Perkins）带领自由乘车之旅穿过博韦尔维尔，抗议对澳大利亚第一民族人民的歧视。
Back then, Bowerville's indigenous residents were barred from the cinema, the RSL, the local school, and even the hospital. By 1990, the segregation wasn't this extreme, yet there was still one pub for white people and another for indigenous people. Those who lived in the community at the time have described the racism as palpable.
当时，博韦尔维尔的原住民居民被禁止进入电影院、RSL、当地学校甚至医院。到 1990 年代，隔离已经没有这么极端了，但仍然有一家白人酒吧和另一家原住民酒吧。当时住在该社区的人形容种族歧视是显而易见的。
But long before Bowerville was ever known as Bowerville, the area was home to the Gumbagya people. They are the traditional custodians of lands sprawling across more than 6,000 square kilometres and have their own distinct language, traditions, and stories. One of their stories has been passed down from elders to children as a cautionary tale. It involves a goomba, an evil spirit that prowls along the banks of a river
但在博韦尔维尔被称为博韦尔维尔很久以前，该地区就是甘巴贾（Gumbagya）人民的家园。他们是跨越6000多平方公里土地的传统托管人，拥有自己独特的语言、传统和故事。他们的一个故事作为警世寓言由长辈传给儿童。它涉及一个冈巴（goomba），一个在河岸边徘徊的邪恶精灵，
looking for children to steal. The goomba is a shapeshifter so he can disguise himself amongst others. This way, he doesn't look suspicious and can prey on his victims when they least expect it, or he'll sit up in a tree looking down and plotting his attack. It's said that he most often waits until night time to strike, leading parents to warn their children that they must always be quiet after dark.
寻找要偷走的孩子。冈巴是一个换形者，所以他可以把自己伪装在其他人中间。这样，他就不会显得可疑，并能在受害者最意想不到的时候捕食他们，或者他会坐在树上向下看并策划他的袭击。据说他通常会等到夜幕降临时才出手，导致父母警告他们的孩子们天黑后一定要保持安静。
Tap. Tap. Tap. Muriel Craig heard a gentle knocking at the window as she bustled around her kitchen, cleaning the mess left over from that evening's meal. It was around nine o'clock and completely dark out. Muriel looked up. It sounded like someone was wrapping up and he heard a gentle knocking at the window
叩。叩。叩。穆里尔·克雷格（Muriel Craig）在厨房里忙碌着，清理着当晚饭后留下的残局，这时她听到窗户传来轻柔的敲击声。当时大约九点钟，外面一片漆黑。穆里尔抬起头。听起来有人在包扎，她听到窗户传来轻柔的敲击声
as she bustled around her kitchen, It sounded like someone was wrapping on the window from outside, but she couldn't see anybody standing there. The experience was almost unsettling until Muriel realized the source of the noise. Crouching out of sight outside was her ten-year-old daughter, Colleen. The little girl was tapping against the glass, trying to scare her mother into thinking there was a ghost outside.
当她在厨房里忙碌时，听起来好像有人在外面敲窗户，但她看不到任何人站在那里。这种经历几乎让人不安，直到穆里尔意识到噪音的来源。蹲在外面视线之外的是她十岁的女儿科琳（Colleen）。这个小女孩正敲打着玻璃，想吓唬她母亲，让她以为外面有鬼。
The mischievous Colleen had a reputation for being a practical joker. She particularly liked playing tricks on her mum, much to Muriel's amusement. As she got older, Colleen kept her sense of humour while also growing up into a responsible young woman. She helped look after her younger siblings, in particular her brother, who was in a wheelchair and had special needs. Colleen hoped to become a preschool teacher one day,
淘气的科琳以恶作剧闻名。她特别喜欢捉弄她的妈妈，这让穆里尔觉得很有趣。随着年龄的增长，科琳保持了她的幽默感，同时也成长为一个负责任的年轻女性。她帮忙照顾年幼的弟弟妹妹，特别是她那个坐轮椅且有特殊需求的弟弟。科琳希望有一天能成为一名学前班老师，
a profession that her friends and family thought would perfectly suit her caring and playful nature. More than six years after Colleen first played a prank on her mother by tapping on a window, Muriel was once again in the kitchen when she suddenly heard a familiar sound. Tap, tap, tap. This time, the noise upset her.
她的朋友和家人认为这个职业非常适合她富有同情心和顽皮的性格。在科琳第一次通过敲窗户恶作剧捉弄母亲六年多后，穆里尔再次来到厨房，突然听到了熟悉的声音。叩，叩，叩。这一次，噪音让她感到不安。
Muriel entered the lounge where her children had gathered and told them off for the practical joke, explaining that they mustn't tap on the window because it was something that Colleen used to do. Muriel's other children insisted that none of them had been outside. They had all been in the lounge the entire time. Their faces were serious and Muriel believed them. Yet, it couldn't have been Colleen either.
穆里尔走进孩子们聚集的客厅，训斥了他们的恶作剧，并解释说他们绝不能敲窗户，因为那是科琳过去常常做的事。穆里尔的其他孩子坚持说他们中没有一个人去过外面。他们整时间都在客厅里。他们的表情很严肃，穆里尔相信了他们。然而，也不可能是科琳。
Colleen, who was now 16 years old, had recently disappeared. Her distraught family had searched tirelessly for her to no avail. As it was clear no one else was responsible for the tapping, Muriel felt certain of one thing. It was her daughter's spirit reaching out, letting her know she was there. Colleen Craig had been excited as she packed her bags in preparation for a holiday.
现年 16 岁的科琳最近失踪了。她心烦意乱的家人不知疲倦地寻找她，但无济于事。由于很明显没有人对敲门声负责，穆里尔确信一件事。那是她女儿的灵魂在联系，让她知道她在那里。科琳·克雷格（Colleen Craig）在收拾行李准备度假时感到非常兴奋。
The teenager was eager to start exploring the world and embrace life as a young adult. She lived with her mother and siblings in the New South Wales town of Sortel, but recently she'd taken a couple of trips to visit family in Bowerville, almost 58km away. Now she was going one step further by travelling with friends. Colleen and three other girls planned to leave Bowerville
这个十几岁的女孩渴望开始探索世界，并以年轻人的身份拥抱生活。她和母亲及兄弟姐妹住在新南威尔士州的索特尔（Sortel）镇，但最近她曾几次去拜访住在近 58 公里外的博韦尔维尔的家人。现在，她要和朋友一起旅行，迈出更远的一步。科琳和另外三个女孩计划离开博韦尔维尔
on the night of September 13, 1990 to catch a 3am train to Sydney. They were headed for the town of Goduga near the Queensland border. It was a long journey with a late start. After she finished packing, Colleen headed over to a party at the Mish, where most of Bowerville's indigenous residents lived. Across the road was a small park where a campfire had been set up for the party. Attendees mingled around the fire and over the road, in the home of a local resident named Marjorie Jarrett.
1990年9月13日晚，赶搭凌晨3点开往悉尼的火车。他们的目的地是靠近昆士兰州边境的戈杜加（Goduga）镇。这是一段漫长的旅程，出发时间很晚。收拾好行李后，科琳前往 Mish 的一个派对，博韦尔维尔的大多数原住民居民都住在那里。马路对面是一个小公园，为派对搭起了篝火。参与者在火堆周围以及马路对面、当地居民玛乔丽·贾雷特（Marjorie Jarrett）的家中来回穿梭。
They also spilled out into a laneway that sat alongside Marjorie's house. Colleen was spotted numerous times throughout the afternoon and evening. Sometimes she sat inside the lounge room and chatted with friends. Other times she was seen with a group gathered beneath a large gum tree in the park opposite. They were drinking beer and Colleen appeared somewhat intoxicated. At around midnight, Colleen was spotted walking down the alleyway alongside Marjorie's house. Hours later, Colleen's three travel companions were preparing to leave for the train station. Marjorie Jarrett had offered to drive the group and searched for Colleen in and around the party with no success.
他们还涌入紧邻玛乔丽房屋的一条小巷。整个下午和晚上，人们多次看到科琳的身影。有时她坐在客厅里与朋友聊天。有时人们看到她和一群人聚集在对面公园的一棵大桉树下。他们当时在喝啤酒，科琳看起来有点醉了。午夜左右，有人看到科琳沿着玛乔丽房屋旁的小巷走去。几小时后，科琳的三个旅伴正准备前往火车站。玛乔丽·贾雷特曾主动提出开车送这群人，并在派对内外寻找科琳，但没有成功。
In the end, Colleen's friends left for their holiday without her. The 3am train to Sydney departed without Colleen on board. As soon as word reached Muriel Craig that her daughter hadn't gone on her trip as planned and hadn't been seen since the party, she knew that something was terribly wrong. Muriel travelled from her home in Sautel to Barreville so she could report Colleen missing. All of the officers at Barreville police station were white. The two who Muriel reported to were dubious when she showed them a picture of Colleen. Noting that the teenage girl had lighter skin than her mother, the officers remarked,
最后，科琳的朋友们在没有她的情况下踏上了假期。开往悉尼的凌晨 3 点的火车出发了，科琳却没有登车。一听到穆里尔·克雷格得知她的女儿没有按计划去旅行，并且自派对以来就再也没有露面，她就知道出大事了。穆里尔从她在索特尔的家赶到巴雷维尔（Barreville），以便她可以报告科琳失踪。巴雷维尔警察局的所有警官都是白人。穆里尔向其中两名警官报案时，他们看了科琳的照片后表现得很怀疑。注意到这个十几岁的女孩皮肤比她母亲白，警官们评论道，
she don't look aboriginal to us and asked if she was really Muriel's daughter. Then they suggested that perhaps Colleen had simply, quote, gone walkabout. In Australia's indigenous cultures, walkabout is a rite of passage in which adolescent males live alone in the wilderness for a period of time. The term has become twisted and misused by non-indigenous people who see aboriginal people as living transient nomadic lifestyles. Some used the word walkabout in a derogatory sense to imply an indigenous person has just taken off on a whim without warning. Muriel was devastated by the policemen's comments and retorted. I wouldn't be silly enough to come in here and report her missing. I am not that stupid. But the officers remained disinterested and unwilling to take a report, remarking that Colleen would probably turn up soon enough.
她看起来不像我们的原住民，并问她是否真的是穆里尔的女儿。然后他们暗示科琳可能只是“去漫游（walkabout）”了。在澳大利亚的原住民文化中，漫游是青春期男性在荒野中独自生活一段时间的成人礼。这个术语被非原住民扭曲和滥用，他们将原住民视为过着短暂游牧生活方式的人。一些人以贬义的方式使用“漫游”一词，暗示原住民在没有任何警告的情况下凭一时冲动离开。穆里尔对警察的言论感到痛心并反驳道。我不会傻到跑来这里报告她失踪。我没那么蠢。但警察仍然表现得漠不关心，不愿立案，并表示科琳可能很快就会出现。
Muriel handed over her photograph of Colleen for their reference, then left the station. With no help from law enforcement, Colleen's family took on the responsibility of finding her. Muriel moved her other children down to Barreville so she could keep searching for Colleen while keeping everyone together. With the help of some relatives, Muriel searched the surrounding areas and spoke to everyone they could find who had been at the party. The police never made any attempt to contact her. Exactly three weeks after Colleen vanished, another party was in full swing at the Mish. This time, the get-together was at Patricia Stadham's house, three doors down from where the previous party had been held. Patricia's daughter Rebecca, who was in her early 20s and lived there too, took her young children over to her ex-partner's house so he could mind them while she was at the party.
穆里尔交出了科琳的照片供他们参考，然后离开了警察局。在没有执法部门帮助的情况下，科琳的家人承担起了寻找她的责任。穆里尔把她其他的孩子搬到了巴雷维尔，这样她就可以继续寻找科琳，同时把大家聚在一起。在一些亲戚的帮助下，穆里尔搜寻了周边地区，并与他们能找到的、参加过派对的所有人进行了交谈。警方从未试图联系她。在科琳失踪整整三 weeks 后，Mish 又举行了一场派对。这一次，聚会在帕特里夏·斯塔达姆（Patricia Stadham）的房子里举行，距离上次派对举行的地方隔了三扇门。帕特里夏的女儿丽贝卡（Rebecca）二十出头，也住在那里，她把自己的幼子带到了前伴侣的房子里，这样他可以在她去派对时照顾他们。
Rebecca and Billy Greenup had a four-year-old daughter named Evelyn, as well as two younger boys Aidan and Aaron. Rebecca was dismayed to discover that Billy was too drunk to look after their young children, so she took them back to her mother's house. After socializing with the party guests, Rebecca decided to go to bed. She slept in the same room as her three children, with four-year-old Evelyn nestled beside her. Rebecca fell asleep fully dressed and didn't wake at all during the night, which was unusual. As soon as she opened her eyes the following morning, Rebecca felt extremely sick in an unfamiliar way. She sat up. Her two sons, Aidan and Aaron, were awake and quietly playing together, but there was no sign of Evelyn. Evelyn and Aaron were very close and rarely left each other's sides, so her absence struck Rebecca as particularly strange.
丽贝卡和比利·格林纳普（Billy Greenup）有一个四岁的女儿伊芙琳（Evelyn），还有两个年幼的男孩艾丹（Aidan）和亚伦（Aaron）。丽贝卡惊恐地发现比利喝得太多，无法照顾他们的幼子，于是她把他们带回了母亲家。与派对客人社交后，丽贝卡决定上床睡觉。她和三个孩子睡在同一个房间里，四岁的伊芙琳依偎在她身旁。丽贝卡和衣入睡，整晚都没有醒来，这很不寻常。第二天一早一睁开眼睛，丽贝卡就感到一种不寻常的极度不适。她坐起身来。她的两个儿子艾丹和亚伦已经醒了，正静静地一起玩耍，但不见伊芙琳的踪影。伊芙琳和亚伦关系非常好，很少离开彼此身边，所以她的缺席让丽贝卡感到格外奇怪。
She asked her boys if they knew where their sister was, but they just looked back at her, wide-eyed and silent. Wondering if Evelyn had wandered off to visit her father, who lived just a few doors down the street, Rebecca first checked at Billy Greenup's house. Evelyn wasn't there, nor was she at any other house in the Mish. Rebecca expanded her search to the centre of Barreville. No one she spoke to had seen Evelyn since the previous night, before the little girl had gone to bed alongside her mother and siblings. Rebecca's panic grew. By mid-morning she was back at home, scouring the surroundings for any sign of her daughter. Suddenly she found something. Lying in the front yard was a single pink sand shoe. It belonged to Evelyn. As word spread about the missing child, an incident that had occurred the previous night took on a sinister new tone. Rebecca's mother Patricia recalled that she'd been woken at around 3am by the sound of Evelyn crying.
她问儿子们是否知道妹妹在哪里，但他们只是睁大眼睛看着她，沉默不语。丽贝卡想知道伊芙琳是否溜出去看望住在街头几步之遥的父亲，于是她首先去了比利·格林纳普的家。伊芙琳不在那里，Mish 的其他房子里也没有她。丽贝卡将搜索范围扩大到巴雷维尔的中心。她与之交谈过的任何人自前一晚小女孩上床睡觉和母亲及兄弟姐妹在一起后就再也没见过她。丽贝卡的恐慌加剧了。到上午中旬，她已经回到家里，在周围寻找女儿的踪迹。突然她发现了一些东西。前院里躺着一只粉红色的沙滩鞋。它属于伊芙琳。随着失踪儿童的消息传开，前一晚发生的一起事件呈现出一种险恶的新基调。丽贝卡的母亲帕特里夏回忆说，她在大约凌晨 3 点被伊芙琳的哭声吵醒。
She got up to check on her, walking down the hall to the room where Evelyn, Rebecca and the two boys were sleeping. The door was closed so Patricia went to open it, but it wouldn't budge. Then she heard a thud, almost like a window being shut, and Evelyn stopped crying. Assuming the little girl had gone back to sleep, Patricia returned to her own room. By evening, Rebecca and her sister Michelle had arrived at the Barreville police station to report Evelyn missing. There was just one officer on duty. Michelle explained the situation and handed the officer a photo. It showed Evelyn with her blue eyes and mop of light brown ringlets, which many people had compared to the hair of famous child actress Shirley Temple. The officer replied,
她起身去查看情况，顺着走廊走到伊芙琳、丽贝卡和两个男孩睡觉的房间。门是关着的，所以帕特里夏去开门，但门纹丝不动。然后她听到“咚”的一声，几乎像是窗户关上的声音，伊芙琳不哭了。帕特里夏以为小女孩又睡着了，便回到了自己的房间。到了傍晚，丽贝卡和她的妹妹米歇尔（Michelle）来到了巴雷维尔警察局报告伊芙琳失踪。当时值班的只有一名警官。米歇尔解释了情况并交给警官一张照片。照片上是伊芙琳，她有一双蓝色的眼睛和一头浅棕色卷曲的头发，许多人将其与著名童星秀兰·邓波儿的头发相提并论。警官回答说，
What do you want me to do? I'm the only one here and I'm just about to go home. Stunned, Michelle repeated that she wanted to report Evelyn missing, explaining that she was just four years old. But the officer wouldn't budge, and it took several more days before Evelyn's family successfully filed a missing persons report. Just as they'd done when Colleen went missing, the police suggested that Evelyn might have, quote, gone walkabout. Yet, they also questioned her indigenous heritage by pointing out her fair skin and blue eyes. Despite taking statements, the police didn't send anybody out to look for Evelyn, and initially her family were left to search for her alone. They called everyone they knew, plastered the town with flyers, and searched high and low through bushland. As so many people had been drinking and partying on the night Evelyn disappeared, it was difficult to piece together what exactly had gone on that night.
你想让我做什么？我是这里唯一的人，我正准备回家。米歇尔惊呆了，重复说她想报告伊芙琳失踪，并解释说她只有四岁。但这名警官态度坚决，又过了好几天，伊芙琳的家人才成功提交了失踪人员报告。就像科琳失踪时一样，警方暗示伊芙琳可能“去漫游了”。然而，他们还通过指出她白皙的皮肤和蓝色的眼睛来质疑她的原住民血统。尽管做了笔录，但警方并没有派任何人出去寻找伊芙琳，最初她的家人只能独自寻找她。他们给认识的所有人打电话，在全镇贴满传单，并在灌木林中上下搜寻。由于许多人在伊芙琳失踪当晚都在喝酒和聚会，很难拼凑出当晚到底发生了什么。
Nevertheless, they knew that she hadn't simply wandered off somewhere. Evelyn was a shy child, who stayed close to her family and was scared of strangers. Three days after Evelyn vanished, the police finally began searching for her, along with volunteers from the local state emergency services. They looked in the nearby Nambucco River and the scrubby bushland that surrounded Bowerville. There was no sign of her. When investigators finally started interviewing people in relation to the case, it was clear that their suspicions fell exclusively on those closest to Evelyn. Her grandmother, Patricia, was interrogated about money that had been transferred into her bank account, with police implying that she and Rebecca had sold Evelyn. In reality, the payments Patricia had received were from her War Widow's pension.
然而，他们知道她并不是随便漫无目的地走开。伊芙琳是一个害羞的孩子，她总是紧紧跟着家人，害怕陌生人。伊芙琳失踪三天后，警方终于开始搜寻她，当地州紧急服务部门的志愿者也加入了搜寻行列。他们在附近的纳姆布科河（Nambucca River）和环绕博韦尔维尔的灌木丛中寻找。没有她的踪迹。当调查人员最终开始就此案对人们进行讯问时，很明显，他们的怀疑完全落在了与伊芙琳最亲近的人身上。她的祖母帕特里夏因转入她银行账户的资金而受到审讯，警方暗示她和丽贝卡把伊芙琳卖了。实际上，帕特里夏收到的款项来自她的战争遗孀抚恤金。
It was also evident that the police had no understanding of indigenous family dynamics, which are more community focused. Because Rebecca had been drinking on the night Evelyn vanished, they assumed her children weren't being looked after. In reality, a wider circle of aunts would always help young parents care for their children. Some news outlets began to pick up the story of the missing four-year-old. When speaking to journalists, the Bowerville police sergeant was adamant. There was absolutely no connection between Evelyn Greenup and the recent disappearance of 16-year-old Colleen Craig. By December of 1990, summer had arrived and brought with it a new resident. Clinton's speedy duro was a 16-year-old boy who had moved from Queensland to Bowerville to live with his father, Thomas Duro.
这也显现出警方根本不了解原住民家庭动态，因为原住民家庭更具社区凝聚力。由于丽贝卡在伊芙琳失踪当晚喝了酒，他们便认为她的孩子没有受到照顾。实际上，更广泛的阿姨圈子总是会帮助年轻父母照顾孩子。一些新闻媒体开始关注这个四岁儿童失踪的故事。在与记者交谈时，博韦尔维尔的警长态度坚决。伊芙琳·格林纳普与 16 岁科琳·克雷格最近的失踪事件之间绝对没有任何联系。到 1990 年 12 月，夏天已经来临，并带来了一位新居民。16 岁的少年克林顿·斯比迪·迪罗（Clinton Speedy Duro）从昆士兰搬到博韦尔维尔，与他的父亲托马斯·迪罗（Thomas Duro）同住。
A sharp dresser who loved footy and had a kind, happy-go-lucky personality, it didn't take long for Clinton to make friends. In particular, he became close to Kelly Jarrett, a teenage girl who had been good friends with Colleen Craig. Clinton and Kelly soon became an item and were rarely seen out of each other's company. On the night of January 31, 1991, the young couple attended a party that was being held around the corner from the Mish, in a public housing flat situated on Herbourne Drive. Rather than go to their respective homes when they were ready to leave, Clinton and Kelly decided to sleep in the yellow Viscount Caravan of a friend. Clinton took off his shoes and the couple watched music videos for a little while, before falling asleep on the same double bed sometime after 3am. Kelly slept soundly. When she woke up, it was 8.40 in the morning.
克林顿衣着时髦，热爱澳式橄榄球，性格善良、随和，没过多久他就交到了朋友。特别是，他与凯利·贾雷特（Kelly Jarrett）走得很近，这是一个曾与科琳·克雷格是好朋友的十几岁女孩。克林顿和凯利很快就成了一对恋人，形影不离。1991年1月31日晚，这对年轻的情侣参加了一个在Mish拐角处、位于赫伯恩大道（Herbourne Drive）的公共住房公寓里举行的派对。准备离开时，克林顿和凯利没有各自回家，而是决定睡在一个朋友的黄色维康大篷车（Viscount Caravan）里。克林顿脱下鞋子，两人看了一会儿音乐录影带，然后在凌晨 3 点之后的某个时间睡在同一张双人床上。凯利睡得很熟。她醒来时，已经是早上 8 点 40 分。
There was no sign of Clinton. Perhaps he'd woken up earlier and already gone home. But then Kelly saw something on the floor of the van, Clinton's Reebok sneakers. Clinton always took pride in his outfits and paid particular attention to his shoes. He never went anywhere barefoot. His father had given him the Reeboks as a Christmas present and Clinton loved them. In his family, it was a source of amusement that he wore them at all times. If Clinton had left already, it made no sense that he'd leave his Reeboks behind. Kelly picked up her boyfriend's shoes and exited the caravan, heading for Clinton's father's house.
没有克林顿的踪影。也许他醒得早，已经回家了。但接着凯利看到大篷车地板上有一样东西——克林顿的锐步运动鞋。克林顿总是为自己的穿着感到自豪，并且特别注意自己的鞋子。他从不光脚去任何地方。他的父亲送给他一双锐步作为圣诞礼物，克林顿非常喜欢它们。在他们家里，他随时随地穿着这双鞋成了一件趣事。如果克林顿已经离开，他把锐步留在身后就说不通了。凯利拿起男友的鞋子，走出大篷车，走向克林顿父亲的家。
Thomas Duro was surprised when he opened his front door to see his son's girlfriend holding Clinton's Reeboks out in front of her. Clinton wasn't at home and the sight of the shoes he was never seen without was immediately alarming. Thomas phoned the police to see if they could do anything to help find Clinton, but they said they couldn't get involved until he'd been missing for at least 24 hours. So, Thomas set out by himself to search for his son. As he did an owner car, he instead walked all over town. First he went to the flats where the party was held the night before, then he visited the caravan where Clinton had spent the night. There was no sign of him anywhere. Thomas checked the town's pubs and other social areas, but nobody he spoke to had seen Clinton since the party.
托马斯·迪罗打开前门，看到儿子的女朋友手里拿着克林顿的锐步鞋伸向前方时，感到非常惊讶。克林顿不在家，看到这双他从不离脚的鞋子立刻让人感到警惕。托马斯打电话给警方，看他们是否能做点什么来帮忙寻找克林顿，但他们说在克林顿失踪至少 24 小时之前他们不能介入。于是，托马斯独自出发去寻找他的儿子。由于他没有车，他只能在全镇步行搜寻。首先他去了前一晚举行派对的公寓，然后他参观了克林顿过夜的大篷车。到处都没有他的踪迹。托马斯检查了镇上的酒吧和其他社交场所，但与他交谈的人中没有人自派对以来见过克林顿。
As the teenager had only just moved to Bowerville, he didn't know many of its residents and there was nowhere obvious he would have visited. Eventually, Thomas decided that all he could do was go home in the hope that Clinton would turn up. He waited and waited, but Clinton never arrived. When the 24 hour time limit had passed, Thomas tried calling the police again to report his son missing. They were in no hurry to respond, waiting another full day before they paid Thomas a visit at home. As Clinton was 16 years old and strongly built, they suspected he'd simply taken off by himself. His family tried to explain to them the significance of Clinton's shoes being left behind, but the officers couldn't understand how this indicated foul play. All they said was, we'll keep an eye out for him.
由于这个少年刚刚搬到博韦尔维尔，他不认识这里的许多居民，也没有他明显会去拜访的地方。最后，托马斯决定他能做的只有回家，祈祷克林顿会出现。他等啊等，但克林顿从未出现。当 24 小时期限过后，托马斯再次尝试打电话给警方报告他儿子失踪。他们并不着急回应，又等了整整一天才去托马斯家拜访。由于克林顿 16 岁且身材健硕，他们怀疑他只是自己一个人跑了。他的家人试图向他们解释克林顿把鞋子留在身后的重要性，但警官们无法理解这如何表明存在谋杀行为。他们所说的一切就是，“我们会留意他”。
Clinton's aunt began making calls, phoning both the local police and law enforcement in the nearby larger city of Coffs Harbour, begging for assistance. Most of her messages went unanswered, but eventually a liaison officer was sent down from Coffs Harbour to help Clinton's family search the town's streets and surrounding areas. Nothing turned up. Just like Colleen Craig and Evelyn Greenup, Clinton's speedy duro had seemingly vanished from Bowerville. Fear spread through the local Indigenous community. Although the police didn't seem to think the three disappearances were linked, the children's friends and family were certain they were. It was a common thread tying the cases together. Over the course of just five months, all of the children had vanished after attending or being in the vicinity of a party at the Mish.
克林顿的阿姨开始打电话，致电当地警察以及附近大城市科夫斯港（Coffs Harbour）的执法部门，恳求援助。她的绝大多数消息都石沉大海，但最终科夫斯港派出一名联络官前往协助克林顿的家人搜寻镇上的街道和周边地区。一无所获。就像科琳·克雷格和伊芙琳·格林纳普一样，克林顿·斯比迪·迪罗似乎也从博韦尔维尔凭空消失了。恐惧在当地原住民社区蔓延。尽管警方似乎认为这三起失踪案没有关联，但孩子们的亲友却确信它们有关联。这是将这些案件联系在一起的共同线索。在短短五个月的时间里，所有这些儿童都是在参加或身处 Mish 的派对附近后失踪的。
They were sure that Colleen, Evelyn and Clinton had been attacked and weren't merely missing persons. When the documentary Innocence Betrayed, Colleen's aunt Elaine Walker told filmmaker Larissa Burrant that residents around the mission changed their behaviour in response to the disappearances. Many mothers started sleeping in the same room as all of their children, so they could keep an eye on them throughout the night. Where residents had once felt safe, they started locking their doors and windows at all times. When children wanted to go into town, their parents would go with them and they'd walk close together in a tight group. A week after Clinton's disappearance, the community's grief and frustration led to a group of Indigenous residents and several white townsfolk marching on Bowerville's police station in protest. They demanded that action be taken and their children's cases be taken seriously. Behind the scenes, Bowerville police had called in colleagues from the child mistreatment unit in Coffs Harbour.
他们确信科琳、伊芙琳和克林顿遭到了袭击，而不仅仅是失踪人员。在纪录片《背叛的天真》（Innocence Betrayed）中，科琳的阿姨伊莱恩·沃克（Elaine Walker）告诉电影制作人拉里萨·伯兰特（Larissa Burrant），教会周边的居民改变了他们的行为以应对失踪事件。许多母亲开始和她们所有的孩子睡在同一个房间里，这样她们可以在整夜密切关注他们。曾经让居民感到安全的地方，现在他们开始时刻锁上门窗。当孩子们想进城时，他们的父母会陪着他们，紧紧地聚集成一个小组步行。克林顿失踪一周后，社区的悲痛和沮丧导致一群原住民居民和几名白人镇民前往博韦尔维尔警察局进行抗议。他们要求采取行动，并严肃处理他们孩子的案件。幕后，博韦尔维尔警方从科夫斯港的儿童虐待部门请来了同事。
Though they'd initially suggested that the missing trio had just quote, gone walkabout, they were starting to suspect that the families themselves and the Indigenous community more broadly were involved. On February 18, almost three weeks since Clinton's speedy duro had disappeared, two men were hiking through some rugged bushland just outside Bowerville. They were looking for firewood in a rough and tangled area that ran alongside Congarene Road, a dirt road that headed south out of town. As they searched for logs amongst the leafletters scattered across the ground, the two men saw something. It was the badly decomposed remains of Clinton's speedy duro. Clinton was barefoot but still dressed in the clothing he'd been wearing on the night he vanished. He had been dragged through the bushland and the animals had scavenged his body. Lying nearby was a blanket which it seemed he had previously been wrapped in.
尽管他们最初暗示失踪的三人只是“去漫游了”，但他们开始怀疑家庭本身以及更广泛的原住民社区卷入了其中。2月18日，距离克林顿·斯比迪·迪罗失踪将近三周，两名男子正在博韦尔维尔郊外的一些崎岖灌木林中徒步旅行。他们正在一条顺着孔加雷恩路（Congarene Road）延伸的粗糙而杂乱的地区寻找柴火，孔加雷恩路是一条向南通往镇外的土路。当他们在散落着落叶的地面上寻找圆木时，这两个人看到了一些东西。那是克林顿·斯比迪·迪罗严重腐烂的遗体。克林顿赤脚，但仍然穿着他失踪当晚穿的衣服。他曾被拖过灌木林，动物们啃食了他的尸体。附近躺着一条毯子，看起来他以前曾被裹在里面。
The area where he had been dumped was also close to a crop of cannabis. An autopsy revealed that Clinton had died from a severe blow to the head. His jaw had been broken and he'd also been stabbed multiple times. Now investigators had to accept that the young man had met with foul play. Two months later on April 17, a man was fishing in the Nambucca River by the southern end of Congarene Road and just down a slight slope from where Clinton had been found. When something snagged his fishing line, he reeled it in. On the end was a pair of jeans and a belt, heavy and soaking wet as they hung off the line. These items were identified as belonging to Colleen Craig.
他被抛弃的地方也靠近一处大麻种植区。尸检显示，克林顿头部遭受重击身亡。他的下巴骨折了，身上还被刺了多刀。现在调查人员不得不接受这个年轻人遭遇不测的事实。两个月后的4月17日，一名男子在孔加雷恩路南端附近的楠布卡河（Nambucca River）钓鱼，距离发现克林顿的地方只有一段微小的下坡。当有什么东西勾住他的钓鱼线时，他把线卷了上来。线上挂着一条牛仔裤和一条皮带，沉甸甸的，挂在在线上还湿漉漉的。这些物品被确认属于科琳·克雷格。
She had been wearing them on the last night anyone had seen her. Police divers subsequently searched the river. By April 20, they had found four plastic bags that had been weighed down in the river. These contained more of Colleen's clothing, including a cable knit jumper she was last seen in. But there was no sign of Colleen herself. A week later on April 27, the police received a phone call from some concerned locals. They had noticed an unpleasant odour in the bushland alongside Congarene Road and were worried given the recent discoveries in the area. The location was three kilometres away from where Clinton's speedy duro was found.
那是任何人最后一次见到她时她穿的衣服。随后警方潜水员搜查了这条河。到 4 月 20 日，他们已经在河里找到了四个被沉重物体压住的塑料袋。这些袋子里装着更多科琳的衣服，包括她最后一次露面时穿的一件粗电缆针织套头衫。但没有科琳本人的踪迹。一周后的 4 月 27 日，警方接到一些热心当地居民的电话。他们注意到孔加雷恩路旁边的灌木林里有一种令人不快的气味，鉴于该地区最近的发现，他们感到很担心。这个地点距离发现克林顿·斯比迪·迪罗的地方有三公里远。
When searches went out there, they discovered the skeletal remains of a small child. It was Evelyn Greenup. A pink sand shoe was recovered near her body, a match to the other shoe her mother had found in the front yard of her home after Evelyn disappeared. Markson Evelyn's skull confirmed that she too had been killed by a heavy blow to the head. The discovery of Clinton and Evelyn's bodies and the clothing belonging to Colleen left Bowerville reeling. The indigenous community in particular was certain that all three of them had fallen prey to a serial killer. There were too many similarities to ignore from the circumstances of their disappearances right down to where their remains and belongings were found. And both Evelyn and Clinton had been killed by fatal blows to the head.
当搜寻人员前往那里时，他们发现了幼儿的骨骼遗骸。那是伊芙琳·格林纳普。在她的尸体附近找到了一只粉红色的沙滩鞋，与她母亲在伊芙琳失踪后在前院找到的另一只鞋相配。伊芙琳头骨上的标志证实，她也是头部受到重击身亡的。克林顿和伊芙琳尸体的发现以及属于科琳的衣服让博韦尔维尔震动。原住民社区尤其确信这三人全都沦为了连串杀人犯的牺牲品。从他们失踪的情况一直到发现他们遗骸和物品的地方，有太多的相似之处不容忽视。而且伊芙琳和克林顿都是头部遭受致命打击身亡。
A homicide investigation was launched with Detective Sergeant Alan Williams at the helm. The detective had no prior homicide experience but was to be assisted by local investigators and other detectives from the North Region Major Crime Squad. Some of the town's white residents queried the amount of resources the investigation was being given with one person remarking to a journalist from the age newspaper. I wonder whether three missing white children would get the same attention. Although Detective Williams had no experience investigating murders, Clinton's remains contained a pivotal clue. A pillowcase that had been pushed down into his shorts. 25-year-old J. Thomas Hart worked at a tanning factory and was reasonably tall at six feet with a stocky but strong 105 kilogram build. Hart wasn't indigenous but he was known to hang out at the Mish and supplied alcohol and cannabis known to locals as Yanni to the young people who lived there.
在侦探警长阿兰·威廉姆斯（Alan Williams）的领导下，谋杀案调查随即展开。这位侦探没有过谋杀案调查经验，但他将得到当地调查人员以及来自北部地区重大案件组的其他侦探的协助。镇上的一些白人居民对调查投入的资源数量提出了质疑，其中一人对《时代报》（The Age newspaper）的一名记者说。我想知道三个失踪的白人儿童是否会受到同样的关注。尽管威廉姆斯侦探没有调查谋杀案的经验，但克林顿的遗骸包含了一个关键线索。一个被塞进他短裤里的枕套。25 岁的 J·托马斯·哈特（J. Thomas Hart）在一家制革厂工作，身高大约六英尺（约 1.83 米），身材魁梧但结实，体重 105 公斤。哈特不是原住民，但他以在 Mish 闲逛而闻名，并向住在那里的年轻人提供酒精和大麻（当地人称为 Yanni）。
Some members of the indigenous community viewed him with suspicion. It seemed to them that Hart showed too much interest in young women and girls. On the night that Clinton's speedy duro had disappeared, he and his girlfriend Kelly had gone to a local party. J. Hart had also been in attendance and made two trips into town to buy beer for the other party-goers. Sometime after midnight, Hart began trying to convince Kelly to come back to the caravan where he lived, which was parked at his mother's home close by. Kelly refused to leave the party without Clinton, so Hart suggested they both join him. The teenagers agreed and left the party with Hart at around 3am. They watched music videos for a little while before going to sleep.
原住民社区的一些成员对他的态度充满了怀疑。在他们看来，哈特对年轻女性和女孩表现出过多的兴趣。在克林顿·斯比迪·迪罗失踪当晚，他和女友凯利去参加了一个当地的派对。J·哈特也出席了，并两次进城为其他派对参加者买啤酒。午夜过后的某个时候，哈特开始试图说服凯利回到他居住的大篷车里，该车停在附近他母亲的家旁。凯利拒绝在没有克林顿的情况下离开派对，于是哈特建议他们俩一起加入。这些青少年同意了，并在凌晨 3 点左右与哈特一起离开了派对。他们看了一会儿音乐录影带，然后去睡觉。
Hart said they could share his double bed and that he would sleep on a fold-out dining table. There was something about Hart that made Kelly uncomfortable and she asked Clinton not to leave her alone with him. She slept deeply that night and woke up alone in the double bed. To Kelly's confusion, she was no longer wearing her shorts or underwear, though she was certain she'd been wearing them when she went to bed. Kelly found her discarded garments on the floor and pulled them back on. Then she picked up Clinton's re-box, which were also on the floor, and went to his father's house to explain that she couldn't find him. When Thomas Duro went out looking for his son that day, he bumped into J. Hart in town. When Thomas asked if he knew where Clinton was, Hart replied that he had gone back home.
哈特说他们可以共用一张双人床，他会睡在折叠餐桌上。哈特身上有些东西让凯利感到不舒服，她要求克林顿不要把她一个人留在他身边。她那天晚上睡得很沉，醒来时独自躺在双人床上。令凯利困惑的是，她身上不再穿着短裤或内衣，尽管她确信自己上床睡觉时穿着它们。凯利在地上找到了她被丢弃的衣服并重新穿上。然后她拿起也掉在地上的克林顿的锐步鞋，去他父亲家解释说她找不到他。当托马斯·迪罗那天外出寻找他的儿子时，他在镇上遇到了 J·哈特。当托马斯问他是否知道克林顿在哪里时，哈特回答说他已经回家了。
But Clinton was never seen alive again. Hart had been identified as a person of interest within days of Clinton's disappearance and police had interviewed him on February 4. A little while after that, officers informed Hart that they would be seizing his caravan to search for forensic evidence, but also out of fear that the town's indigenous residents might, quote, trash it. They agreed that he could remove some personal belongings before they took possession of the vehicle and to ask what he wanted. Hart replied, just me waits. The officers let Hart retrieve the barbells and take them away. Forensic detective Rob Wellings wouldn't learn that the suspect had been allowed to remove some of his possessions until sometime afterwards.
但克林顿再也没有活着出现过。在克林顿失踪几天内，哈特就被确定为相关嫌疑人，警方于 2月4日对其实施了讯问。在那之后不久，警官们通知哈特，他们将没收他的大篷车以搜寻法医证据，同时也出于担心镇上的原住民居民可能会“毁了它”的恐惧。他们同意他在他们接管车辆之前拿走一些个人物品，并询问他想要什么。哈特回答说，只要我的杠铃。警官们让哈特取回了杠铃并将它们带走。法医侦探罗布·韦林斯（Rob Wellings）直到一段时间后才知道嫌疑人被允许带走他的一些财产。
The small caravan was dirty and in disarray, with Detective Wellings later telling journalists to den box of the Australian that it was more like a squat than a proper home. Though it was searched at the time, a proper forensic examination wasn't completed. A few days later, Clinton's remains were found. Detective Wellings was called out to the scene and as he examined Clinton's body, he noticed a piece of fabric shoved down the front of his shorts. Detective Wellings carefully removed the fabric and on closer inspection, he saw that it looked very familiar. It looked like an exact match to a set of pillowcases he'd seen in Jay Hart's caravan when he'd examined it a few days earlier. Detective Wellings immediately notified his colleagues of the disturbing discovery and investigators interviewed Hart again. He adamantly denied having anything to do with Clinton's murder.
这个小大篷车很脏而且一片混乱，韦林斯侦探后来告诉《澳大利亚人报》（The Australian）的记者，它与其说是一个像样的家，不如说是一个私占的窝棚。虽然当时搜查了，但并未进行彻底的法医勘验。几天后，人们发现了克林顿的遗骸。韦林斯侦探被叫到现场，当他检查克林顿的尸体时，他注意到一块塞在他短裤前面的布料。韦林斯侦探小心翼翼地取下布料，仔细一看，他发现它看起来非常熟悉。它看起来与他几天前检查 J·哈特的大篷车时看到的一套枕套完全吻合。韦林斯侦探立即将这一令人不安的发现通知了他的同事，调查人员再次讯问了哈特。他坚决否认与克林顿的谋杀有任何关系。
Hart acknowledged that he'd invited Clinton and Kelly back to his caravan and had a few drinks with Kelly while Clinton lay on the double bed. Then, Hart set his alarm for between 5.15 and 5.30 so he could get up in time for his six o'clock shift at the tanning factory before falling asleep drunk. When the alarm went off, Hart was so hungover that he automatically hit the snooze button and dozed off again. But he slept so lightly that he could still hear someone else in the caravan get up and leave. At around 5.45, Hart woke and prepared for work. Although he had already organised for a colleague to give him a lift that day, Hart thought he'd missed him due to oversleeping, so he went into his mother's house and asked to borrow the keys to her orange-red galant. Then, he headed off to work by himself.
哈特承认他曾邀请克林顿和凯利回到他的大篷车，并在克林顿躺在双人床上时和凯利喝了几杯。然后，哈特将闹钟定在 5 点 15 分到 5 点 30 分之间，以便他能准时起床去制革厂上 6 点钟的早班，随后醉醺醺地睡着了。闹钟响时，哈特宿醉得厉害，他本能地按下了贪睡按钮又打了个盹。但他睡得很轻，仍然能听到大篷车里的另一个人起身离开。大约 5 点 45 分，哈特醒来并准备上班。尽管他已经安排好那天由一位同事开车接他，但哈特以为自己睡过头错过了，于是他走进母亲家，借了她那辆红橙色加兰（Galant）的钥匙。然后，他独自一人开车去上班。
Hart's colleague confirmed that he had arrived to pick up Hart just before 6am. When he peaked inside the van, he saw Kelly's feet sticking out of the bed but no sign of Hart or Clinton. The colleague decided to go to work without Hart. As he prepared to leave, he spotted Hart pull up to the property in his mother's car. According to Hart, he'd seen his colleague arrive when he glanced in his rearview mirror. He'd told his colleague to go to work without him, as he'd decided he needed a cup of tea to treat his hangover before starting his shift. About 20 minutes later, Hart turned up at work. He stayed there for a couple of hours before going back home to return his mother's car.
哈特的同事证实他在快到早上 6 点时到达接哈特。当他探头看车内时，他看到凯利的脚从床上伸出来，但不见哈特或克林顿的踪影。同事决定不等哈特去上班。正当他准备离开时，他看到哈特开着他母亲的车驶来。据哈特说，他从后视镜里瞥见同事到达时看到了他。他告诉同事不用等他直接去上班，因为他决定在上班前喝杯茶来治治宿醉。大约 20 分钟后，哈特出现在工作地点。他在那里待了几个小时，然后回家归还了他母亲的车。
While he was back at the property, his voice woke Kelly, who was still sleeping in the caravan. Investigators weren't buying Hart's story. It was refuted by other witnesses. As well as the colleague who had seen him heading towards the property instead of away from it, multiple people had seen indicators that Hart was up when he said he was asleep. His mother's boyfriend had noticed a light on in Hart's caravan at around 4.30am, just before leaving for his own job. A neighbour saw Hart's mother's car drive away from the property about 20 minutes later, an hour before Hart said he'd borrowed it. His mother Marlene had previously told the police she kept her keys in a handbag at the end of her bed, leading them to theorise that Hart had crept into her room and taken them while she was sleeping.
当他回到住处时，他的声音惊醒了还在大篷车里睡觉的凯莉。调查人员并不相信哈特的话。他的说法被其他证人驳斥了。除了那个看到他走向住处而不是离开住处的同事之外，还有好几个人看到迹象表明，哈特在他说自己已经睡着的时候其实还醒着。他母亲的男友注意到，大约在凌晨4点30分，就在他自己出门上班之前，哈特的房车里亮着灯。一个邻居看到哈特的母亲的车在大约20分钟后驶离了住宅，而这比哈特说他借车的时间早了一个小时。他的母亲玛琳此前曾告诉警方，她把钥匙放在床头的手提包里，这让警方推测哈特趁她睡着时悄悄溜进她的房间拿走了钥匙。
Marlene had also said that Hart used blankets similar to the one found near Clinton's body. This time, Jay Hart wasn't allowed to leave his police interview as a free man. He was charged with murder. When Colleen's clothing and Evelyn's remains were found in the same area as Clinton's body in the weeks that followed, some began wondering whether Jay Hart would be charged with their murders as well. For months, residents on the Mish had been murmuring his name in relation to the two missing girls. Years earlier, Jay Hart had been in a relationship with Colleen's aunt, Alison. The couple had a son together, but Hart was verbally and physically abusive towards Alison, so she left for Queensland, taking their son with her.
玛琳还曾说过，哈特使用的毯子与在克林顿尸体附近发现的毯子相似。这一次，杰伊·哈特没能以自由之身离开警察局的审讯室。他被控谋杀。在接下来的几周里，当科琳的衣服和伊芙琳的遗体在克林顿尸体同一区域被发现时，一些人开始怀疑杰伊·哈特是否也会被指控谋杀她们。几个月来，“米什”社区的居民一直在私下议论他的名字，将他与这两名失踪女孩联系起来。几年前，杰伊·哈特曾与科琳的姑姑艾莉森谈过恋爱。两人育有一个儿子，但哈特对艾莉森有言语和肢体虐待，因此艾莉森带着儿子搬去了昆士兰州。
Colleen Craig, who was nine years younger than Hart, was familiar with him due to his relationship with Alison. When Colleen visited Bowerville in July 1990, Hart stopped by the Mish and spent some time talking to her and her friend Patricia. He invited the two girls to his caravan to watch music videos and stay over. He also invited another male friend. Colleen and Patricia agreed when Hart said they could share his double bed and he would sleep alone. But when the girls woke the next morning, Hart was in bed with them, sleeping soundly. Colleen told Patricia that she'd been woken during the night by Hart climbing into the bed and trying to have sex with her. She added,
比哈特小九岁的科琳·克雷格因为他和艾莉森的关系对他并不陌生。1990年7月科琳访问鲍尔维尔时，哈特顺道来到“米什”，花了一些时间与她和她的朋友帕特里夏交谈。他邀请这两个女孩去他的大篷车看音乐录影带并留宿。他还邀请了另一个男性朋友。当哈特说她们可以共用他的一张双人床而他自己一个人睡时，科琳和帕特里夏同意了。但第二天早上女孩们醒来时，哈特却和她们躺在床上，睡得很熟。科琳告诉帕特里夏，半夜里她被哈特爬上床并试图与她发生性关系的行为惊醒了。她补充说：
He mauled me all night. He touched down below and up the top as well. This morning, I had to pull my pants up when I woke. He'd got them down during the night. Though Colleen had been exhausted, she'd managed to fight Hart off. Patricia had slept more heavily than Colleen, but she recalled that earlier in the night, she had overheard Hart ask their male friend, Do you want to have sex with the girls? Their friend had replied, No, leave them alone. After this incident, Colleen was wary of the older man. She went back home to Sortel, then returned to Baraville a few months later in September.
他整晚都在对我动手动脚。他下面上面都碰了。今天早上我醒来时，不得不把裤子拉上去。他半夜把裤子褪下去了。尽管科琳已经精疲力竭，但她还是设法把哈特推开了。帕特里夏睡得比科琳沉，但她回忆说，在当晚早些时候，她无意中听到哈特问他们的男性朋友：“你们想和女孩们发生性关系吗？”他们的朋友回答：“不，别管她们。”这起事件后，科琳对这个年长的男人保持着戒心。她回到了索特尔，几个月后的9月又回到了巴拉维尔。
On the night of September 13, she attended a party at the Mish, hours before she was planning to board a 3am train to Sydney. Jay Hart was at the party as well. Colleen's friends noticed how much attention he was paying her, constantly asking her to stay another night in his caravan. Colleen complained about Hart's behaviour, telling others he was harassing and pestering her. She was last seen walking down the alleyway that boarded the house where the party was taking place. Hart was also spotted at the same time, following her along the other side of the house. Some of the circumstances around the disappearance of 4-year-old Evelyn Greenup were chillingly familiar. Like Colleen, Evelyn's mother Rebecca had found herself receiving a lot of attention from Jay Hart.
9月13日晚上，她在“米什”参加了一个聚会，几个小时后她就打算登上凌晨3点去悉尼的火车。杰伊·哈特也在派对上。科琳的朋友们注意到他多么关注她，不停地要求她在他的大篷车里多住一晚。科琳抱怨哈特的行为，告诉其他人他在骚扰和纠缠她。她最后一次被人看到是走进了那栋正在举行派对的房子旁边的巷子里。与此同时，也有人看到哈特在房子的另一侧跟踪她。围绕着4岁女孩伊芙琳·格林纳普失踪的一些情况，有着令人不寒而栗的熟悉感。和科琳一样，伊芙琳的母亲丽贝卡发现自己受到了杰伊·哈特的极大关注。
He had attended the party at their family home on the night Evelyn vanished. After the party was over and Rebecca had gone to bed with her three children, Hart stayed on, loitering in the house. Rebecca's mother Patricia had asked Hart to leave, then went to change into her pyjamas. When she left her room, she saw no sign of Hart and assumed he'd gone home. Several hours later, Patricia was woken by a sharp cry from Evelyn. She got up to check on her granddaughter, but couldn't get into the room where she was sleeping. Patricia heard a heavy thud, then all went silent. At the time, she didn't suspect anything untoward had happened.
在伊芙琳失踪的那天晚上，他曾参加他们家族住所的聚会。派对结束后，丽贝卡带着三个孩子上床睡觉了，而哈特却留下来，在房子里闲逛。丽贝卡的母亲帕特里夏要求哈特离开，然后去换睡衣。当她离开房间时，她没有看到哈特的踪影，以为他已经回家了。几个小时后，帕特里夏被伊芙琳的一声尖叫惊醒。她起床去查看孙女的情况，却进不去她睡觉的房间。帕特里夏听到一声沉闷的撞击声，然后一切都安静了。当时，她并没有怀疑发生了什么不寻常的事情。
The next morning, Rebecca woke from an uncharacteristically heavy sleep. Glancing down, she saw that the jeans she was wearing were unbuttoned and down around her knees. Her underwear was also pulled to one side. Rebecca had no recollection of undressing herself. Clinton's girlfriend Kelly Jarrett had reported a similar experience on the night her boyfriend disappeared while staying at Hart's caravan. And Colleen had told a friend that Hart pulled her pants off while she was sleeping. There was another crucial detail. Another woman had stayed at Patricia's house after the party and was preparing a bottle for her baby just after Patricia went to check on Evelyn.
第二天早上，丽贝卡从异乎寻常的沉睡中醒来。低头一看，她发现自己穿的牛仔裤解开了扣子，滑到了膝盖周围。她的内衣也被拉到了一边。丽贝卡完全不记得自己是怎么脱衣服的。克林顿的女友凯莉·杰瑞特曾在男友在大篷车留宿并失踪的那天晚上报告过类似的经历。科琳也曾告诉朋友，哈特在自己睡觉时把她的裤子脱了。还有一个至关重要的细节。另一个女人在派对结束后留在了帕特里夏的家里，就在帕特里夏去查看伊芙琳的情况后不久，她正在为自己的孩子冲奶瓶。
Moments after Patricia went back to bed, the woman saw Jay Hart leave the room where Rebecca and her children were sleeping. He hurried down the hallway towards the front door. Wondering why he was leaving in such a rush, the woman followed him. But by the time she reached the front door and looked outside, he was nowhere to be seen. A forensic examination of Hart's caravan had revealed a tiny speck of human blood on his bed. But experts weren't able to determine any more information than that. The sample was so small that it was destroyed during the forensic process. Although investigators had an abundance of circumstantial evidence linking Hart to all three disappearances, there was little in the way of physical evidence.
就在帕特里夏回到床上后不久，那个女人看到杰伊·哈特从丽贝卡和她的孩子们睡觉的房间里出来。他沿着走廊急匆匆地朝前门走去。那个女人纳闷他为什么走得这么急，便跟了过去。但等她走到前门往外看时，他已经不见踪影了。对哈特大篷车的法医检查在他的床上发现了一小点人类血液。但专家们除了这一点无法确定更多信息。样本太小，在法医鉴定过程中被毁了。尽管调查人员掌握了大量将哈特与这三起失踪案联系起来的间接证据，但物理证据却少之又少。
And when it came to Colleen Craig's case, the fact that they hadn't found her body would make securing a conviction difficult. Almost six months after Evelyn Greenup's remains were found, Hart was charged with her murder on October 16, 1991. The director of public prosecutions was hopeful that Clinton and Evelyn's cases could be prosecuted in a single trial, allowing evidence from each case to be presented side by side. But Jay Hart's legal team sought to have the two separated, arguing that their client would be unfairly prejudiced by a joint trial. Ultimately, the judge ruled in the defense's favor, ordering that Hart be trialed separately for each count. Moreover, prosecutors wouldn't be allowed to present evidence from the other cases at trial. Clinton's case had the strongest evidence and would run first.
而在科琳·克雷格的案件中，他们一直没有找到她的尸体，这使得获取定罪变得困难。在伊芙琳·格林纳普的遗体被发现近六个月后，1991年10月16日，哈特被控谋杀她。公共检察官希望克林顿和伊芙琳的案件可以在一次庭审中被起诉，从而允许来自两个案件的证据并排呈递。但杰伊·哈特的法律团队试图将两案分开，他们争辩说，联合审判会对他们的当事人造成不公正的偏见。最终，法官做出了有利于辩方的裁决，下令对哈特的每一项指控进行单独审判。此外，检察官在审判中将不允许出示其他案件的证据。克林顿的案子拥有最强有力的证据，并将首先开庭。
Prosecutors were barred from mentioning the murder of Evelyn or the disappearance and suspected murder of Colleen. In early 1994, the trial for Clinton's speedy duro's murder began. Although the prosecution was somewhat limited in what they could present, Clinton's family were confident that Hart would be convicted. The prosecution was arguing that Hart had spiked Kelly's drink and attempted to rape her. He killed Clinton after the teenager woke, saw the attack, and tried to stop him. Then, he stole his mother's car keys from her handbag at around 4.45am after her boyfriend left for work and placed Clinton's body in the vehicle. He drove to Congarene Road to dump Clinton's body in the bush. A neighbor had seen Marlene Hart's car leave the property at around this time and Hart's colleague saw it return more than an hour later.
检察官被禁止提及谋杀伊芙琳或科琳失踪及涉嫌谋杀的事情。1994年初，克林顿·斯皮迪·杜罗谋杀案的审判开始了。尽管检方在他们能提交的内容方面受到了一定的限制，但克林顿的家人相信哈特会被定罪。检方辩称，哈特在凯莉的饮料中下了药并企图强奸她。当这个十几岁的少年醒来、看到袭击并试图阻止他时，他杀死了克林顿。然后，大约在凌晨4点45分在她男友去上班后，他从手提包里偷走了他母亲的车钥匙，把克林顿的尸体放进车里。他开车去孔加里尼路把克林顿的尸体扔进灌木丛。一位邻居看到玛琳·哈特的车大约在这个时候离开了住处，哈特的同事看到它在一个多小时后返回。
Kelly Jarrett was able to give first-hand testimony that her boyfriend had gone to sleep in Hart's caravan but had vanished without his shoes by the time she woke to find her clothing removed. But the defense undermined Kelly's evidence by focusing on the fact that she had been drinking on the night in question. Other Indigenous witnesses who were called to share their recollections of Hart being at the party were similarly scrutinised. The defense also called two people who claimed to have seen Clinton alive and well the morning after it was alleged he'd been killed. Jay Hart testified in his own defense, telling the court how he had heard Clinton leave the caravan when he was half asleep. A little while later, at around 5.45am, he'd borrowed his mother's car keys and left for work. Although Hart's mother originally told police she kept her keys in a handbag at the end of her bed, she told the court that she slept with them under her pillow. Early that morning, she was woken by her son coming into her room and asking if he could borrow her car.
凯莉·杰瑞特能够提供第一手证词，称她的男友去哈特的房车睡觉了，但当她醒来发现自己的衣服被脱掉时，男友已经光着脚失踪了。但辩护方通过把焦点放在她在案发当晚喝过酒这一事实上，削弱了凯莉证据的效力。其他被传唤分享他们对哈特在派对上的回忆的土著证人也受到了类似的盘问。辩护方还传唤了两个人，他们声称在据称克林顿被杀的第二天早上看到克林顿活得好好的。杰伊·哈特在自己的辩护中出庭作证，向法庭讲述了他是如何在半梦半醒之间听到克林顿离开房车的。过了一会儿，大约在凌晨5点45分，他借了他母亲的车钥匙去上班。尽管哈特的母亲最初告诉警方，她把钥匙放在床头的手提包里，但她在法庭上说，她把钥匙放在枕头底下睡觉。那天清早，她被儿子走进房间并询问是否可以借她的车给吵醒了。
Marlene said when she glanced at the clock, she saw it was 5.50am. She also denied ever saying that Hart used blankets like the one found near Clinton's body and claimed the police had incorrectly inserted that into their records. The trial concluded on February 18, three years to the day after Clinton's body was found. Clinton's family and friends sat in silence as they waited for the jury's verdict to be read aloud. The jury, who had no idea that others had been murdered, let alone that Jay Hart was suspected of killing them, found Hart not guilty. Shock washed over Clinton's family and friends as they realised that Hart had been acquitted. Clinton's grandmother fainted. As they left the courtroom in a daze, members of the media descended with cameras and microphones, clamouring for a response to the verdict.
玛琳说，当她看了一眼时钟时，发现是早上5点50分。她还否认曾说过哈特使用过类似于在克林顿尸体附近发现的毯子，并声称警方错误地将这一点记录在案。庭审于2月18日结束，这正好是克林顿尸体被发现整整三年的那一天。克林顿的家人和朋友静静地坐着，等待陪审团的裁决被宣读出来。陪审团根本不知道其他人被谋杀，更不知道杰伊·哈特涉嫌杀害他们，他们裁定哈特无罪。当克林顿的家人和朋友意识到哈特被判无罪时，震惊席卷了他们。克林顿的祖母晕倒了。当他们精神恍惚地离开法庭时，大批媒体蜂拥而至，带着摄像机和麦克风，吵着要对裁决作出回应。
When the family was ushered into another room so they could have some privacy, photographers and camera crews climbed up to the windows trying to get footage of them. Clinton's 16-year-old brother Troy was so traumatised by these events that he later had no recollection of them. Jay Hart's acquittal through the prosecution. Of the two counts that they had charged Hart with, they'd thought Clinton's was the strongest. Now that a jury had found in his favour, they didn't think they had a chance of successfully prosecuting him at another trial, especially since they couldn't introduce any evidence used at the previous one. Ultimately, the director of public prosecutions decided to drop the second charge. Jay Hart would not have to answer for his alleged involvement in the murder of Evelyn Greenup. The victims' families and their community were devastated.
当家属被护送到另一个房间以便保有隐私时，摄影师和摄像团队爬到窗户上试图拍摄他们的画面。克林顿16岁的弟弟特洛伊由于这些事件受到极大创伤，以至于后来对它们毫无记忆。杰伊·哈特的无罪释放打破了检方的希望。在他们指控哈特的两个罪名中，他们认为克林顿的案子是最有力的。现在既然陪审团作出了有利于他的裁决，他们认为自己没有机会在另一次审判中成功起诉他，特别是由于他们无法引入在先前审判中使用的任何证据。最终，公共检察官决定撤销第二项指控。杰伊·哈特将不必为他涉嫌参与谋杀伊芙琳·格林纳普承担责任。受害者的家属和他们的社区悲痛欲绝。
The grief they had endured ever since the three children disappeared intensified as they grappled with the feeling that the legal system had failed them. When they first lost their children, no one had cared. Now, more than three years later, it seemed they were still all alone in their quest for justice. Unwilling to give up, they continued to fight for Colleen Evelyn and Clinton. Over the next few years, demonstrations were held regularly in Bowerville as a way for residents to express their anger and frustration. In response to their grievances, the Commissioner of New South Wales Police met with the community and eventually agreed to reinvestigate the three murders. In January 1997, a new strike force was established. Experienced investigators and analysts from Homicide, Major Crime and North Region Local Area Commands would take over the case, led by Detective Gary Jubalon.
自从三个孩子失踪以来，他们所承受的悲痛加剧了，因为他们一直在努力应对法律系统让他们失望的感觉。当他们第一次失去孩子时，没有人关心。现在，三年多过去了，在他们追求正义的道路上，似乎依然孤立无援。他们不愿放弃，继续为科琳、伊芙琳和克林顿而战。在接下来的几年里，鲍尔维尔定期举行游行示威，作为居民表达愤怒和沮丧的一种方式。为了回应他们的不满，新南威尔士州警察局长会见了社区，并最终同意重新调查这三起谋杀案。1997年1月，一个新的打击小组成立了。来自凶杀案、重大犯罪和北部地区地方警察指挥部的经验丰富的调查人员和分析师将接手该案，由侦探加里·朱巴隆领导。
A renowned homicide detective, Gary Jubalon was known for his dedication to solving crimes and the strong rapport he built with victims' families. When he began working on the Bowerville murders, Detective Jubalon couldn't believe that a case involving two teens and one child, who all lived on the same street and had gone missing from the same area within a five-month period, hadn't been treated more seriously. The fact that the prime suspect had been allowed to remove possible evidence from his caravan was also alarming. Hart had subsequently thrown away the barbells that he retrieved from the van, and they were never found. Forensic experts suspected that they could have been used to deal the fatal blow to Clinton's head. As well as reexamining evidence relating to the case and chasing down new and previous witnesses alike, Detective Jubalon and his team placed a strong emphasis on strengthening ties with the Indigenous community. Realising the family's trust in law enforcement was at an all-time low, the detectives undertook training in cultural sensitivity and awareness. Individual investigators worked diligently to connect with the town's folk.
加里·朱巴隆是一位著名的凶杀案侦探，以其对侦破犯罪的奉献精神以及与受害者家属建立的深厚关系而闻名。当他开始调查鲍尔维尔谋杀案时，朱巴隆侦探简直不敢相信，一个涉及两个青少年和一个儿童的案件——他们都住在同一条街上，并且在五个月内从同一个地区失踪——竟然没有受到更严肃的对待。首要嫌疑人被允许从他的大篷车中移除潜在证据，这同样令人震惊。哈特后来扔掉了他从房车里拿出来的杠铃，这些杠铃再也没有被找到。法医专家怀疑这些杠铃可能被用来对克林顿的头部造成了致命的一击。除了重新检查与案件相关的证据并追查新老证人之外，朱巴隆侦探和他的团队还高度重视加强与土著社区的联系。意识到家属对执法的信任度处于历史最低点，侦探们进行了文化敏感性和意识方面的培训。个别调查人员努力与镇上的人民建立联系。
Gradually, they were able to form more positive relationships with the victim's families and Bowerville's Indigenous residents. Investigators were soon making new discoveries about the case. One particularly interesting piece of information related to an incident that occurred after Colleen's disappearance, but prior to Evelyn's. There was a residence on the mission nicknamed the Women's House, as only women lived there. Not long after Colleen vanished from a party nearby, one of the home's occupants woke up one night with a start. It was about 2am and she sensed something was wrong. Looking up, the woman saw the figure of a man standing in her room. There was something about his stance that looked threatening.
逐渐地，他们能够与受害者的家属以及鲍尔维尔的土著居民建立更积极的关系。调查人员很快对该案有了新的发现。其中一个特别有趣的信息与科琳失踪之后、伊芙琳失踪之前发生的一起事件有关。任务区里有一处住所被称为“妇女之家”，因为只有女性住在那里。就在科琳在附近的一个派对上失踪后不久，该住所的一名住户在一个夜晚突然惊醒。当时大约是凌晨2点，她感觉到有什么不对劲。抬起头，这个女人看到一个男人的身影站在她的房间里。他的某种站姿看起来颇具威胁性。
Though she was initially frozen with fear, the woman sat up. Her sudden movement prompted the man to flee. She had never told the original case investigators about this unsettling incident. When members of the strike force asked her why not, she replied, I'm a black lady, what's the point of telling the white coppers? As far as Gary Jubiland was concerned, her story was consistent with the theory that investigators were leaning towards. Colleen, Evelyn and Clinton had disappeared as part of a string of sexually motivated attacks targeting indigenous women living on the mission. Evelyn's mother Rebecca and Clinton's girlfriend Kelly had both woken up from strangely deep sleeps to find their pants removed and their loved ones missing.
虽然她起初吓得僵住了，但那个女人还是坐了起来。她突如其来的动作促使那个男人逃跑了。她从未向最初的案件调查人员讲述过这起令人不安的事件。当打击小组成员问她为什么不这样做时，她回答说：“我是一个黑人女性，告诉白人警察有什么意义呢？”就加里·朱巴隆而言，她的说法与调查人员倾向的理论是一致的。科琳、伊芙琳和克林顿的失踪是一系列以居住在传教区的土著妇女为目标的性动机袭击事件的一部分。伊芙琳的母亲丽贝卡和克林顿的女友凯莉都在异常深沉的睡眠中醒来，发现她们的裤子被脱掉了，而她们的挚爱却失踪了。
Colleen Craig had once complained of Jay Hart mauling her and pulling off her clothing during the night. Her friend Patricia, who had been with her that night, said they'd both felt groggy and she had slept deeply. Some people who attended parties on the mission said Jay Hart regularly supplied alcohol and was known for spiking people's drinks. He also seemed to show a predatory interest in indigenous women. In early 1998, the strike force passed along their submissions to the director of public prosecutions. They were recommending that new charges be brought against Jay Hart for the murder of Evelyn Greenup. It took 18 months for the DPP to respond. Ultimately, they decided against pressing charges, citing a lack of evidence.
科琳·克雷格曾抱怨杰伊·哈特在夜间对她动手动脚并脱掉她的衣服。她的朋友帕特里夏当晚和她在一起，她说她们两个都觉得头昏脑涨，而且她自己睡得很沉。一些参加传教区派对的人说，杰伊·哈特经常提供酒精，并以在人们的饮料中下药而闻名。他对土著女性也似乎表现出掠夺性的兴趣。1998年初，打击小组将他们的意见书转交给公共检察官。他们建议以谋杀伊芙琳·格林纳普的罪名对杰伊·哈特提出新的指控。检方花了18个月的时间才作出回应。最终，他们以证据不足为由，决定不予起诉。
Dissatisfied with this, the family's community and members of the strike force kept petitioning for action to be taken. It took six more years, but a coronial inquest was finally granted in February 2004. The inquest would focus on the disappearance of Colleen and the murder of Evelyn. Unlike the previous trial, the coroner would be able to examine all of the available evidence. Seven months later, the coroner handed down his findings. Despite the DPP's previous decision that there wasn't enough evidence to press charges, he stated that there was a reasonable prospect a jury could convict a known individual of Evelyn's murder. Even though Colleen Craig's body had never been discovered, the coroner found that she had died as a result of homicide.
对此感到不满，家属社区和打击小组成员继续请愿采取行动。又过了六年，死因裁判官研讯终于在2004年2月获得批准。研讯将重点关注科琳的失踪和伊芙琳的谋杀案。与先前的审判不同，验尸官将能够检查所有可获得的证据。七个月后，验尸官发布了他的调查结果。尽管检方先前裁定没有足够的证据提出指控，但他表示，陪审团很有可能判定某知名个人犯有谋杀伊芙琳罪。尽管科琳·克雷格的尸体从未被找到，但验尸官裁定她死于凶杀。
The consistencies between the three cases led him to believe that they must be linked and were the act of a single individual. He added that there was a definite suspicion on the only person of interest. The coroner would be urging the director of public prosecutions to try Jay Hart again. The DPP did as requested, and a Jay Hart was once again charged with Evelyn Greenup's murder. The trial began on February 6, 2006. As Hart had already been acquitted of Clinton's murder, none of the evidence from that case was admissible. And once again, the trial judge ruled that some evidence from Colleen's case would have to be excluded, as it could prejudice the jury. But the prosecution would be allowed to mention how multiple women Hart showed an interest in had awoken to find their pants and underwear removed, including Evelyn's mother, Rebecca.
这三起案件之间的一致性使他相信它们必定是相互关联的，并且是一个人的行为。他补充说，对唯一的利益相关者存在明确的怀疑。验尸官将敦促公共检察官再次审判杰伊·哈特。检方按照要求做了，杰伊·哈特再次被指控谋杀伊芙琳·格林纳普。审判于2006年2月6日开始。由于哈特已经被判克林顿谋杀罪名不成立，该案的所有证据均不具可采性。审判法官再次裁定，科琳案的一些证据必须被排除在外，因为这可能会对陪审团产生偏见。但检方将被允许提及哈特表现出兴趣的多名女性如何在醒来时发现她们的裤子和内衣被脱掉，其中包括伊芙琳的母亲丽贝卡。
The prosecution's theory was that Hart had been in the process of assaulting a sleeping Rebecca when Evelyn woke and began to cry. Out of rage and a desire to silence the little girl, Hart had picked her up and thrown her at a wall, before carrying her limp body away and dumping her in bushland. New witnesses also testified that Hart had made disturbing comments to them during altercations. An indigenous couple from the Mish said that in April 1990, Hart had threatened to strangle them, then dump their bodies near the Yarny Plants on Congerini Road. Yarny was an indigenous word for cannabis, and there had been a cannabis crop near the areas where Clinton and Evelyn were found. Another man testified that Hart had told him he had bodies buried in some Yarny crops, and a prison inmate said that while Hart was awaiting trial, he had admitted to killing Evelyn by slamming her head against a wall. But, due to the restrictions placed on them, the prosecution wasn't able to detail much of the evidence uncovered by Gary Jubiland's strike force. The defense team undermined the prosecution's witnesses by claiming one was, quote, a drunk, and that the prisoner who testified was previously convicted of perjury.
检方的理论是，哈特当时正在袭击熟睡的丽贝卡，这时伊芙琳醒来并开始哭泣。出于愤怒和让小女孩闭嘴的渴望，哈特抱起她并把她扔向墙壁，然后搬走她瘫软的尸体并将其扔进灌木丛中。新的证人还作证说，哈特在争吵时曾对他们发表过令人不安的评论。来自“米什”的一对土著夫妇表示，1990年4月，哈特曾威胁要勒死他们，然后把他们的尸体扔在孔格里尼路的雅尼植物附近。“雅尼”是土著语中的大麻，在发现克林顿和伊芙琳的地区附近曾有大麻作物。另一名男子作证说，哈特曾告诉他，他在一些雅尼作物中埋了尸体，一名狱警说，当哈特等待审判时，他曾承认通过将伊芙琳的头部撞向墙壁来杀死她。但是，由于对他们施加了限制，检方无法详细说明加里·朱巴隆打击小组发现的大多数证据。辩护团队通过声称其中一人是“酒鬼”，并且作证的囚犯先前曾因伪证罪被定罪，从而削弱了检方证人的可信度。
Just as they had done during Clinton's trial, they described how numerous people said they had seen Evelyn the morning after she went missing. A Barreville shopkeeper said the little girl had come into her store at 7am that day. Witnesses from the victim's families were already confused by the restrictions placed on them in terms of what they could or couldn't say. The fact that 15 years had passed made it even easier for the defense to cast doubt upon their recollections. At times, Evelyn's relatives felt as though they were the ones on trial. Her mother Rebecca was grilled about her drinking habits and sexual partners. She couldn't fathom why there seemed to be more focus on her than the man charged with killing Evelyn. This time, Hart didn't take the stand.
正如他们在克林顿审判期间所做的那样，他们描述了许多人如何表示他们在伊芙琳失踪的第二天早上看到过她。巴尔维尔的一位店主说，那天早上7点，这个小女孩曾走进她的商店。受害者家属的证人已经对在他们能说或不能说的话方面对他们施加的限制感到困惑。15年过去了，这使得辩方更容易对他们的回忆产生怀疑。有时，伊芙琳的亲属觉得好像是他们自己在受审。她的母亲丽贝卡受到关于她的饮酒习惯和性伴侣的嚴厲盘问。她无法理解为什么人们似乎更多地关注她，而不是被指控杀害伊芙琳的那个男人。这一次，哈特没有出庭作证。
On March 3, one month after the trial began, the jury delivered their verdict. Not guilty. Jay Hart had been acquitted once again. Evelyn's family were devastated, as was their broader community and the relatives of the other victims. Now that Jay Hart had twice been found not guilty, the victim's families felt they had little chance of ever receiving justice. Double jeopardy laws in New South Wales meant that an individual couldn't be prosecuted again for a crime they had already been acquitted of. But this changed in December 2006. Due in part to campaigning by the families, the New South Wales Parliament made an amendment to the State's Crimes Appeal and Review Act.
3月3日，在审判开始一个月后，陪审团作出了裁决。无罪。杰伊·哈特再次被判无罪。伊芙琳的家属悲痛欲绝，他们的更广泛社区以及其他受害者的亲属也是如此。既然杰伊·哈特已经两次被判无罪，受害者的家属觉得他们永远伸张正义的机会渺茫。新南威尔士州的双重危险法律意味着一个人不能因其已经被判无罪的罪行再次被起诉。但这在2006年12月改变了。部分由于家属的竞选活动，新南威尔士州议会修改了该州的《刑事上诉和审查法》。
Now, someone who had been acquitted could be retrialed if fresh and compelling evidence was found. The strike force got back to work and began investigating again. They established that witness sightings of Clinton and Evelyn the morning after they went missing were not correct, and that people had either confused their dates, been mistaken, or were misremembering things. As part of their re-investigation, the strike force also uncovered a crucial piece of information that had been completely ignored until now. At around 5am on the morning of February 1, 1991, delivery drivers Greg Innes and Michael Scaffidi were driving towards Bowerville. They had a load of meat to drop off at the town butcher, and the road stretched out in front of them, dim in the pre-dawn hours. The bright headlights of their truck cast a strong light across their path, while their surroundings faded into darkness. Travelling at a speed of about 80km per hour, the men swung left as they came to a corner on that side, a stretch of road known locally as Norco Corner.
现在，如果发现了新的且令人信服的证据，曾经被判无罪的人可以被重新审判。打击小组重新开始工作，并开始再次调查。他们确定，证人在克林顿和伊芙琳失踪第二天早上看到他们的目击并不是正确的，人们要么搞错了日期，要么弄错了，要么记错了事情。作为重新调查的一部分，打击小组还发现了一个直到现在完全被忽视的关键信息。1991年2月1日凌晨5点左右，送货司机格雷格·英尼斯和迈克尔·斯卡菲迪正开车前往鲍尔维尔。他们有一车肉要送到镇上的肉店，破晓前的几个小时里，道路在他们面前延伸，昏暗不明。卡车耀眼的车头灯在他们的前路上投下了强光，而周围的环境则漸漸隐入黑暗。以大约每小时80公里的速度行驶时，这几个人在转弯处向左转，这段路当地人称为诺科角。
It was then that their truck's high beams illuminated something. A young indigenous man was lying on the road. He had the smooth and youthful face of a teenager, and had a shirt tied around his waist. There were no shoes on his feet. One hand was stretched above his head, which was turned to one side, and he was completely still. As Michael later told the Sydney Morning Herald, it looked like he was either asleep, drunk, or dead. Watch out, there's some guy on the road, he warned Greg. The two men pulled over and parked the truck, then peered out of the window at the person sprawled across the road.
正是在那时，他们的卡车远光灯照亮了某些东西。一个年轻的土著男子躺在路上。他有着青少年般光滑年轻的脸庞，腰上系着一件衬衫。他的脚上没有鞋子。一只手举在头顶上方，头偏向一边，他一动不动。正如迈克尔后来对《悉尼先驱晨报》所说的那样，他看起来要么是睡着了、喝醉了，要么就是死了。“小心，路上有个家伙，”他警告格雷格。这两个人把车停在路边，然后透过车窗向横卧在路上的那个人望去。
They saw there was also a stocky white man at the scene, and he was standing over the boy as though to help him. Leaning across from the passenger seat, Michael asked, Mate, what's going on? We could have hit that guy, he's lying in the middle of the road. The white man reassured Michael and Greg that everything was fine. The indigenous boy was just asleep, and he'd called the police to pick him up. Michael checked whether the man wanted some help in carrying the teenager off the road, but the man waved him off, saying he could manage by himself. Believing the situation was under control, the two delivery men pulled back onto the road and continued on their way.
他们看到现场还有一个身材魁梧的白人男子，他站在那个男孩上方，好像要帮他一样。迈克尔从副驾驶座位探过身去问：“伙计，怎么回事？我们差点撞到那家伙，他躺在路中间。”那名白人男子向迈克尔和格雷格保证一切都好。那个土著男孩只是睡着了，他已经叫了警察来接他。迈克尔查看那个人是否需要帮忙把少年抬离道路，但那个人挥手示意他离开，说他自己能应付。两个送货员相信局势已经得到控制，便把车开回路上，继续他们的行程。
Up ahead, they noticed what looked like a mustard-coloured station wagon parked to one side. Its boot was open, and its lights were off. When Greg and Michael later heard that a 16-year-old named Clinton Speedy Juro had been found murdered in some nearby bushland, they realised the significance of what they had seen. The morning that they had seen a seemingly unconscious indigenous boy lying on the ground was the same day that Clinton was believed to have been attacked. Perhaps the boy's killer had been hoping that a vehicle would run over the body, making it look like an accident instead of murder.
前方，他们注意到一辆看起来像芥末色的旅行车停在一边。它的后备箱开着，车灯关着。当格雷格和迈克尔后来听说一个名叫克林顿·斯皮迪·杜罗的16岁男孩被发现谋杀在附近的灌木丛中时，他们意识到了他们所见所闻的重要性。他们看到一个看似失去知觉的土著男孩躺在地上的那天早晨，正是克林顿被认为遭到袭击的日子。也许男孩的凶手曾希望一辆车会碾过尸体，让它看起来像是一场事故而不是谋杀。
The two men reported the incident to police. When Gary Jubiland's team were once again investigating the case in 2007, they found a running sheet from April 1991 that detailed the men's sighting. But the information had never been properly investigated or made available at the trial for Clinton's murder. The original detectives hadn't even obtained formal statements from Greg and Michael. In 2016, Michael Scaffidi shared another detail with the journalist at Dandbox. A couple of years after he'd observed the strange scene at Norco Corner, he had been at work when some colleagues began passing around photographs from a community event in Bowerville.
这两个人向警方报告了这一事件。当加里·朱巴隆的团队在2007年再次调查此案时，他们发现了一张来自1991年4月的行动记录表，其中详细记录了这些人的目击情况。但这些信息从未得到适当的调查，也没有在克林顿谋杀案的审判中提供。最初的侦探甚至没有从格雷格和迈克尔那里获得正式证词。2016年，迈克尔·斯卡菲迪与《达恩博克斯》的记者分享了另一个细节。在他观察到诺科角诡异场景几年后，他在上班时，一些同事开始传阅鲍尔维尔一次社区活动的相片。
Michael was looking at the photos when one person in a picture caught his eye. He asked his coworkers if they knew who the person was, and they flipped the photo over to read some names that had been scribbled on the back. According to these annotations, the person Michael had noticed was Jay Hart. Michael was certain that Hart was the man he'd seen with the indigenous boy at Norco Corner years earlier. Detective Jubiland and his team believed that the Norco Corner sighting constituted fresh and compelling evidence. On behalf of the New South Wales police force, they made a submission that Hart be retried for the murders of Clinton and Evelyn
迈克尔正在看照片时，照片中的一个人引起了他的注意。他问同事是否知道这个人是谁，他们把照片翻过来阅读写在背后的几个名字。根据这些注释，迈克尔注意到的那个人是杰伊·哈特。迈克尔确信哈特就是他多年前在诺科角与那个土著男孩在一起的那个男人。朱巴隆侦探和他的团队认为，诺科角目击事件构成了新的且令人信服的证据。他们代表新南威尔士州警察部队提交了一份意见书，要求对哈特进行克林顿和伊芙琳谋杀案的重新审判，
and indicted for the murder of Colleen Craig. But on June 4, 2007, the DPP advised that the new evidence wasn't sufficiently fresh or compelling. Their application was denied. Over the years, the lack of answers and resolution in the three Bowerville murders has attracted attention from the media. The case has been featured in a number of high-profile television programs and was the subject of a 2013 documentary by Indigenous writer, legal academic and filmmaker Larissa Burrant. She travelled to Bowerville to interview the victims' families, and her film titled Innocence Betrayed won and was shortlisted for several awards.
并起诉谋杀科琳·克雷格。但在2007年6月4日，律政司通知说，新证据不够新或不够引人注目。他们的申请被拒绝了。多年来，鲍尔维尔三起谋杀案中缺乏答案和结果吸引了媒体的关注。该案已在许多备受瞩目的电视节目中播出，并成为土著作家、法律学者和电影制作人拉里萨·伯兰2013年纪录片的主题。她前往鲍尔维尔采访了受害者的家属，她名为《背叛的纯真》的电影赢得了多个奖项并入围决赛。
Three years later, the Australian newspaper released a podcast series about the case. Crime journalist Dan Box interviewed Colleen, Evelyn and Clinton's families as well as various witnesses. He also spoke with Jay Hart at length. In their conversation, Hart, who has changed his name and no longer lives in Bowerville, strenuously denied having anything to do with the murders. He even stated that he wouldn't be opposed to being trialled again, as he believed it would provide him with the opportunity to clear his name once and for all. The series shone a new spotlight on the case and led to a renewed push for action.
三年后，《澳大利亚人报》发布了一系列关于此案的播客。犯罪记者丹·博克斯采访了科琳、伊芙琳和克林顿的家属以及各种证人。他还与杰伊·哈特进行了长谈。在他们的谈话中，已经改名且不再住在鲍尔维尔的哈特坚决否认与这些谋杀案有任何关系。他甚至表示，他不反对再次受审，因为他相信这会为他提供洗清自己罪名的一次机会。该系列节目为该案带来了新的聚光灯，并促使人们再次推动采取行动。
As it turned out, the laws on admissibility of evidence had recently been updated, meaning that details of Colleen and Evelyn's cases would now be admissible in a trial for Clinton's murder. In February 2017, police charged Hart with Clinton and Evelyn's murders yet again. The New South Wales Attorney General applied to the state's court of criminal appeal for a retrial on the grounds that these new laws effectively gave rise to fresh and compelling evidence. The following year, this application was rejected, with the court ruling that none of the evidence was fresh. The Attorney General applied to Australia's High Court for special leave to appeal this decision, but was denied. To this day, Jay Hart maintains he had nothing to do with the murders of Evelyn Greenup or Clinton's speedy duro,
事实证明，关于证据可采性的法律最近已进行了更新，这意味着科琳和伊芙琳案件的细节现在将在审判克林顿谋杀案时具有可采性。2017年2月，警方再次以克林顿和伊芙琳谋杀案起诉哈特。新南威尔士州总检察长向该州的刑事上诉法院申请重新审判，理由是这些新法律有效地产生了新的且令人信服的证据。第二年，这一申请被驳回，法院裁定所有证据都不是新的。总检察长向澳大利亚高等法院申请特别许可对这一决定提出上诉，但遭到拒绝。直到今天，杰伊·哈特坚称他与伊芙琳·格林纳普或克林顿·斯皮迪·杜罗的谋杀案无关，
or the disappearance of Colleen Craig. He asserts that the evidence against him is purely circumstantial, and he's the only suspect because police botched their investigation, neglecting to look at any other persons of interest. Hart recently spoke with Indigenous filmmaker Alan Clarke for a forthcoming documentary titled The Bowerville Murders and told Clarke, Police haven't got a single witness that's seen me do anything. They haven't got a single piece of forensic evidence to tie me to them. Not one piece.
或者与科琳·克雷格的失踪无关。他断言针对他的证据纯属间接证据，他是唯一的嫌疑人，因为警察搞砸了他们的调查，忽略了调查任何其他相关人员。哈特最近与土著电影制作人艾伦·克拉克就即将上映的纪录片《鲍尔维尔谋杀案》进行了交谈，并告诉克拉克：“警察连一个看到我做任何事的证人都没有。他们连一件将我与他们联系起来的法医证据都没有。连一件都没有。”
Case file acknowledges Jay Hart's right to the presumption of innocence. Colleen, Evelyn and Clinton's families are still fighting for a retrial. The victims' loved ones have no doubt that the case would have been treated very differently if they weren't Indigenous. From the start, police dismissed their concerns due to the prejudices about their community. Michelle Jarrett, the aunt of Evelyn Greenup, has said that if Colleen's disappearance was taken seriously, then Evelyn and Clinton might still be alive today. When two of the cases later went to trial, Indigenous witnesses found themselves up against a legal system that was foreign to them. The juries selected didn't include any Indigenous people and they weren't educated on Indigenous communication styles,
案卷承认杰伊·哈特享有无罪推定权。科琳、伊芙琳和克林顿的家属仍在为重新审判而战。受害者的亲人们毫不怀疑，如果他们不是土著人，这个案件的处理方式会大不相同。从一开始，由于对他们社区的偏见，警察就对他们的担忧置之不理。伊芙琳·格林纳普的姑姑米歇尔·杰瑞特曾说过，如果科琳的失踪被认真对待，那么伊芙琳和克林顿今天可能还活着。后来其中两个案件进入审判程序时，土著证人发现自己面对的是一个对他们来说陌生的法律系统。挑选的陪审团不包含任何土著人，也没有对他们进行有关土著沟通方式的教育，
which possibly led to witnesses being misinterpreted as untrustworthy. For example, some Indigenous witnesses would say yes as a polite response to being asked a question before going on to give evidence that contradicted what jurors heard as their previous answer. In 2016, the New South Wales Police Commissioner Andrew Scipione met with all three families to formally acknowledge that institutional racism had hindered the initial handling of the case. He stated, I want to publicly acknowledge that the New South Wales Police Force could have done more for your families when these crimes first occurred and how this added to your pain as a grieving community.
这可能导致证人被误解为不可信。例如，一些土著证人在被问及问题时会礼貌地回答“是”，然后继续提供与陪审团听到他们之前的回答相矛盾的证据。2016年，新南威尔士州警察局长安德鲁·西皮奥内会见了所有三个家庭，正式承认机构性种族主义阻碍了案件的初期处理。他表示：“我想公开承认，当这些罪行首次发生时，新南威尔士州警察部队本可以为你们的家属做更多的事情，以及这如何加剧了你们作为哀痛社区的痛苦。”
And for that, I am sorry. Colleen Craig's family have never stopped looking for her body. In 2011, they thought they might have found her when some bones were discovered not far from Bowerville, but these turned out to be animal remains. To this day, Colleen's siblings, cousins, nephews and nieces still search for her. The fact that she has never been found has contributed to their grief. As one of Colleen's cousins told a parliamentary committee, it is something that is missing within all of us.
“为此，我深感抱歉。”科琳·克雷格的家属从未停止寻找她的尸体。2011年，当在鲍尔维尔附近发现一些骨头时，他们以为可能找到了她，但这些骨头被证明是动物遗骸。直到今天，科琳的兄弟姐妹、表亲、侄女和外甥女仍在寻找她。她一直没有被找到的事实加剧了他们的悲痛。正如科琳的一位表亲告诉议会委员会的那样，这是我们所有人心中所缺失的一部分。
Not actually knowing where she is and what has happened to her is something that we carry every single day. Those closest to Evelyn Greenup have battled guilt as well as sorrow. Her grandmother Patricia has suffered as she heard Evelyn cry out on the night in question but was unable to reach her. Evelyn's mother Rebecca has also been tormented by the fact that Evelyn went missing from the same room where she was sleeping. In the years after her daughter's death, Rebecca directed her pain inwards and struggled with alcoholism. In her own words, My heart was ripped apart and I felt numb as I knew Evelyn was never coming back to me. I would never be able to give her a hug or give her a kiss, tell her everything is alright,
不知道她在哪里、她发生了什么，是我们每天都在承受的事情。伊芙琳·格林纳普最亲近的人除了悲伤之外，还在与内疚作斗争。她的祖母帕特里夏在事发当晚听到伊芙琳哭喊却无法接触到她，为此饱受折磨。伊芙琳的母亲丽贝卡也受到伊芙琳在自己睡觉的同一个房间里失踪这一事实的折磨。在她女儿死后的几年里，丽贝卡将她的痛苦转向内收，并与酒精中毒作斗争。用她自己的话说：“我的心碎了，我感到麻木，因为我知道伊芙琳永远不会回到我身边了。我再也不能给她一个拥抱或一个吻，告诉她一切都会好起来的，”
and I would never see my daughter grow up into a beautiful woman. I was always treated like I had no right to Evelyn's information on updates of the investigation and I was always left out of everything because everyone blamed me. No one will ever know how I feel because I was Evelyn's mother and had that special bond with her. I carried her for nine months. I felt her move and grow in my womb and I gave birth to my first born child, Evelyn Clarice Greenup. Even though Clinton's speedy duo was the first victim found,
“我也永远不会看到我的女儿长成一个美丽的女人。我一直被当作我对伊芙琳关于调查更新的信息没有权利，我总是被排挤在一切之外，因为每个人都责怪我。没有人会知道我的感受，因为我是伊芙琳的母亲，与她有着那种特殊的联系。我怀了她九个月。我感到她在我的子宫里移动和生长，我生下了我的第一个孩子，伊芙琳·克拉丽丝·格林纳普。”尽管克林顿·斯皮迪·杜罗是被发现的第一个受害者，
it later emerged that the police had not done a thorough job in bringing him back to his family. A year after Clinton's murder, two bones belonging to him were found in the bush. His family learnt of this oversight 12 years after they lost Clinton when his autopsy report was accidentally shared with them. This was an extremely painful discovery, especially as the burial of human remains is a very sensitive matter within indigenous culture. Clinton's family members still struggled to speak of the boy they lost, due in part to the sense of injustice they feel from the trial's outcome in 1994. His brother Troy has said he had difficulty even speaking to his wife about Clinton
后来发现，警方在将他送回家人身边这件事上并没有做好彻底的工作。在克林顿遇害一年后，人们在丛林中发现了属于他的两根骨头。在他去世12年后，当他的尸检报告被不小心分享给他们时，他的家人才得知这一疏忽。这是一个极其痛苦的发现，特别是在原住民文化中，安葬人类遗体是一件非常敏感的事情。由于1994年审判结果带来的不公感，克林顿的家人们至今仍很难谈论这个失去的男孩。他的弟弟特洛伊曾说，他甚至很难和妻子谈论克林顿
and has never really learned how to deal with the pain and loss of trust in the justice system. The constant battle with the police, the legal system and the government over the past three decades has left all of Clinton's loved ones feeling despondent. The younger generation has picked up the fight from their parents, but the last thing they want is for future generations to have to do the same thing. In Clinton's father's words, Each time we think we are going to get justice, we are let down. We keep going, but it is hard.
并且从未真正学会如何应对痛苦以及对司法系统失去的信任。在过去的三十家里，与警方、司法系统以及政府的不断抗争，让克林顿所有的亲人都感到沮丧。年轻一代从父母手中接过了这场抗争，但他们最不希望看到的就是后代也不得不这样做。用克林顿父亲的话说，每次我们以为能得到公正时，都会失望。我们一直在坚持，但这很难。
Those who knew Colleen Craig described her as vibrant, kind and well-liked. She had a tender and loving nature, as demonstrated by her care for younger children. Her family said she had a strong character with a clear moral compass, while still being something of a prankster who liked to make jokes. At the time that she disappeared, Colleen had completed a certificate and some work experience in preparation for achieving her dream of becoming a preschool teacher. Before she left her hometown of Sortel to go to Barreville in the days before her death, she kissed her mother goodbye.
认识科琳·克雷格的人都形容她充满活力、善良且受人喜爱。她天性温柔慈爱，她对年幼孩子的照顾就是明证。她的家人说她性格坚强，有着清晰的道德底线，同时又有点喜欢恶作剧和开玩笑。在失踪前，科琳已经完成了一个证书课程并积累了一些工作经验，为实现她成为一名幼儿园老师的梦想做准备。在她离开家乡索特尔前往巴雷维尔的前几天，她吻别了母亲。
Colleen and her mum Muriel had a special bond, and everyone who knew them was sure Colleen would never go anywhere without telling Muriel of her plans. Despite never being reunited with her daughter, Muriel still feels her presence. Not long after Colleen disappeared, Muriel heard a familiar tapping at her kitchen window. Although Colleen wasn't out there, Muriel felt in her heart that the noise was her daughter's spirit reaching out. Evelyn Greenup was shy with the outsiders and scared of strangers. When her family went for walks together, four-year-old Evelyn would cling tightly to an adult's hand. But closer to home, her personality shone.
科琳和她的妈妈穆丽尔有着特殊的纽带，所有认识他们的人都确信，科琳在不告诉穆丽尔她的计划之前，是绝对不会去任何地方的。尽管再也没能与女儿团聚，穆丽尔依然能感受到女儿的存在。在科琳失踪后不久，穆丽尔听到她厨房的窗户上传来熟悉的敲击声。虽然科琳并不在那里，但穆丽尔心里觉得那个声音是女儿的灵魂在与她接触。伊夫林·格林纳普对局外人很害羞，对陌生人感到害怕。当她的家人一起散步时，四岁的伊夫林会紧紧抓着大人的手。但在家里附近时，她的个性就展现出来了。
Evelyn loved visiting her aunties and playing with her cousins and two little brothers. Sweet and gentle, she always had a smile on her face and especially liked being outside in nature. Clinton's speedy duro was nicknamed Bubby by his family. Sometimes they jokingly called him pretty boy because he took so much pride in his clothes and appearance. His passions were art, music and dancing. When he hit the dance floor at parties, all lies were drawn to him. He was also a talented football player, helping his team to win the under-16s grand final by scoring two tries. Clinton had a reputation for being friendly and kind to younger children,
伊夫林喜欢探望阿姨们，和表兄弟姐妹以及两个弟弟一起玩。她甜美温柔，脸上总是带着微笑，尤其喜欢大自然。克林顿·斯皮迪·迪罗被家人昵称为“巴比”。有时他们开玩笑叫他“漂亮男孩”，因为他非常注重自己的衣着和外表。他的爱好是艺术、音乐和跳舞。当他在派对的舞池上时，所有的目光都被他吸引。他也是一名出色的橄榄球运动员，通过两次达阵帮助球队赢得了16岁以下组的决赛。克林顿以对年幼儿童友好和善良而闻名，
with one of his aunts remembering how kids would trail behind him wherever he went. A monument to Colleen Craig, Evelyn Greenup and Clinton's speedy duro was built at Barreville's Memorial Park. Six wooden benches form a circle around three poles, each of which features a plaque dedicated to one of the victims. The three poles are linked by a triangular rooftop, creating a small sheltered area where people can gather. Colleen, Evelyn and Clinton's families were all consulted for the memorial. It was envisioned as a place where they and the community can reflect on the loss of their three children and honour their memories. The victims' loved ones were overcome with anger after their most recent application for a retrial was rejected by Australia's High Court. To protest the ruling, they plastered the windows of Sydney's law courts building with white painted handprints.
他的一个阿姨回忆说，孩子们无论他走到哪里都会跟在他身后。在巴雷维尔纪念公园里，建立了一座纪念科琳·克雷格、伊夫林·格林纳普和克林顿·斯皮迪·迪罗的纪念碑。六张木制长椅围成一个圆圈，环绕着三根柱子，每根柱子上都有一块专门为其中一位受害者设立的牌匾。三根柱子由一个三角形的屋顶连接，创造了一个人们可以聚集的小遮蔽区。科琳、伊夫林和克林顿的家人都参与了纪念碑的咨询。它被构想为一个地方，让他们和社区能够反思失去这三个孩子的悲痛并缅怀他们。在澳大利亚高等法院驳回了他们最近的重审申请后，受害者的亲人们愤怒不已。为了抗议这一裁决，他们在悉尼法院大楼的窗户上印满了白色手印。
In a voice thick with emotion, an aunt of Clinton's speedy duro told journalists, We are stuck in a 29 year rut of injustice. We are owed. You owe us this justice. How dare you all? You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
克林顿·斯皮迪·迪罗的一位阿姨带着充满情感的沙哑声音对记者说：“我们陷入了长达29年的不公泥潭中。我们被欠着。你们欠我们这份公正。你们怎么敢这样？你们……”本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。